the Joe Rogan experience flying knees in
MMA is like when one lands you know
you're seeing guys land them now like
the Maas Badal fight with Ben aspirins
are the best example of all time
like god damn that but in more tied that
is so rare it's hard to let me clean my
as well and I've tried myself quite a
lot of times when I'll be fine he's hard
to land a clean one to the face you see
like the the Dutch what anyone about
earlier they've got it down because what
they do is to unload with the hands make
you cover tight right and then drive it
straight from Italy guard and they've
great down to an art then but like for
actual flying jumping one like right
across the ring he's out to London which
Alden landed one ball Khaldun yeah yeah
there's just so in in MMA it's like you
never know if a guy's gonna shoot and we
had wrestlers that that desire to go and
dive on your legs and then boom you're
caught with that flying my mother dolmas
Conlon versus the other man watching
your reaction don't fingers well but you
know when you realize that he planned
for that and then he actually set it up
by moving to his right to force Ben to
definitely lead with the left leg
forward
I mean he really went to that side and
then came at him so Ben's instinct he
couldn't avoid it yeah it's like that's
his thing is to get a hold of you and
like here it's right on him and then he
comes right up the middle just gotta go
avoiding and all this [ __ ] talk and that
went on before that fight that was it
just a devastating loss
yeah same time and he's coming back
really quickly against Demian Maia
died and that's an interesting fight
because Demian Maia is a [ __ ] and
strangler he was out on a hill who's not
bad yeah right so to have him fight just
four months later it's like mmm brave
yeah and maybe not I mean what if Demian
Maia decides to stand up bang with them
yeah I mean if anybody looked Damien
mind can take you out with his hands no
doubt about it and if anybody is capable
of
dolphin takedowns or reversing position
as a grappler Damien Myers a spectacular
grappler yeah
[Applause]